this video is made possible by brilliant
you're gonna learn more about brilliant
later in today's video but if you'd like
to learn more about them right now go to
brilliant dot org
forward slash bar graphics you'll also
find a link in the description below if
you were alive during the 80s and 90s
that's likely a single name you
associate with the word science Carl
Sagan was the most popular scientist of
his era a guy who could take complex
abstract concepts and make them
understandable for millions a trained
astrophysicist who worked on some of
NASA's most famous missions Sagan was
also the man who turned a generation
onto the wonders of our own solar system
but while most of us probably only know
Sagan's public persona the one he
assumed to present PBS as classic 1980
series cosmos how many of us know the
man himself born into a working-class
Brooklyn neighborhood Sagan worked hard
to become the most eminent scientist in
America but he also caught it
controversy pioneering ideas that made
him as many enemies as he had adoring
fans inspiring insightful egotistic
seductive this is the life of Carl Sagan
the man who brought astronomy to the
people on clear nights in Brooklyn it's
still possible to just make out the
Stars despite the lights pollution tiny
pinpricks of Lights faintly visible
through New York City's a tunnel orange
glow they act as a comfort to some and a
romantic backdrop for others the young
Carl Sagan gazing up but those same
stars eighty years ago they acted as
something else entirely
a mystery born Carl Edwards Sagan on
November the 9th 1931 in Brooklyn Carl
was a boy with plenty of time on his
hands for thinking his father Samuel
works back raking hours in the garment
industry while his mother Rachel was
strongly religious and very active in
the local reformed Jewish community as a
result young Carl spent many hours left
to his own devices hours that he spent
trying to get answers to a seemingly
simple question what worth
stars that he could see finding out the
truth was harder than it sounded
according to Sagan most of the adults he
asked would reply with things like well
they're just lights in the sky but the
boy he knew that they had to be
something more than that
they were lights sure but what were
these lights what were they made of how
did they get there well the answer to
that question is gonna change
young car's life sent by his mother to
New York Public Library aged either 5 or
7 the number changes depending on who is
telling the story the boy asked for a
book on the stars in an oft told tale in
later life Seguin wood recounts how the
librarian initially gave him a book on
Clark Gable and Greta Garbo eventually
though the boy got his book on astronomy
back in Brooklyn he sat down to find the
answer to his question the Sun the book
said is a star but close-up the stars
are Suns but far away for I raised on
generations of science programs that
might sound kind of like a bit of a well
yeah duh moments but for the young boy
from Brooklyn it was a revelation those
lights in the sky
they were other Suns each may be circled
by their own worlds each may be shining
down on some alien city where another
boy looked at the heavens and wondered
what those lights were in that moment
Karl's conception of the universe had
expanded as suddenly as the universe
itself did after the Big Bang a Sagan
would later remark the universe now
seemed a whole lot bigger than Brooklyn
the discovery turned the boy into a
veritable science fiction nut he
devoured the Martian novels of Edgar
Rice Burroughs and began plotting to get
himself abducted by aliens in 1945 when
he heard of Hitler's v2 rockets falling
on England's the boy thought only of how
he could take one of those rockets and
ride it to another world instead his
father he took him to New Jersey in 1947
Samuel Sagan was making enough money to
move his family out of New York and into
a middle-class neighborhood by now young
Carl was 13 and he was obsessed with
UFOs in fact it's easy to imagine at
this point that this biography could
turn into that of a great science
fiction writer Karl made his first ever
radio broadcast around this time telling
audiences of a local college station
that aliens were visiting earth yes it
wouldn't be fiction that supplied Karl
and outlet for his feelings of awe about
space in 1951 after graduating high
school Karl enrolled at the University
of Chicago to study physics
it was while there that Sagan came to
the attention of Gerard Kuiper the man
for whom the Kuiper belts on the fringes
of our solar system is named Kaipara is
known today as the father of planetary
science and Kuiper well he was about to
transform young Carl Sagan into his
protege on October the 5th 1957 a
strange speck of light streaks through
the skies above Earth if any children
out there looked up and asked their
parents what that light was they
wouldn't have gotten the answer the Carl
Sagan once hat this wasn't a star it was
Sputnik one the first man-made satellite
ever put into space and it was about to
kick off the space race for Sagan the
flight of Sputnik 1 was the capstone to
an eventful year that June had married
Lynn Alexander and the two were already
planning to start a family at the same
time as PhD advisor jarred Kuiper was
getting Sagan extra credit work on a
top-secret US government projects to
detonate a nuclear bomb on the moon it'd
probably be glad to hear that project
never went anywhere but Kuiper's
influence it was still exerting a pull
on the younger man like an object in the
Kuiper belt drawn inexorably towards the
Sun Sagan was being pulled toward
planetary science the planet that
eventually captured him well I would be
Venus that's not a clever metaphor for
love here the actual planet Venus was
the focus of Sagan's thesis in part
because it was still such a mystery at
the end of the 1950s all scientists knew
about venus was that it was covered in
clouds Mannie still assumed rolling
oceans or maybe even humid jungles lay
below the atmosphere Sagan knew these
beliefs out of the extra-terrestrial
water under the supervision of Kuiper he
theorized that Venus was a hellish
planet with an atmosphere hot enough to
melt let not long after it was proven
right the
theses through a spotlight on Sagan
barely had he graduated in 1960 then he
was snapped up by the University of
California Berkeley to help build
instruments for NASA's Mariner 2 mission
two years later he was poached to work
at Harvard University and the
Smithsonian Astrophysical Observatory it
was while at Harvard that Sagan
identified Mars's epic swirling dust
storms
it was also while at Harvard that Sagan
got seriously into aliens for all his
reputation may have grown Sagan was at
heart still a kid fantasizing about life
on Mars
as the sixties got underway and free
love and copious marijuana used blew
through university corridors in a cloud
of green smoke Sagan began writing books
on the existence of aliens he got
involved with SETI the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence known by
another name at that point it was the
pet project of Frank Drake at Cornell
University but there was a story there
was a much bigger for Sagan's personal
life the breakdown of his marriage in
1962 Sagan divorced Lynn Alexander and
watched as she took the kids away four
years later on April the 6th 1986 he
married the artist Linda salesmen that
same year they can change jobs yet again
his fascination with aliens had made the
planetary scientists something of an
embarrassment to Harvard so it was with
mutual relief that Sagan applied for a
job at Cornell working alongside his new
SETI buddy Frank Drake at the laboratory
for planetary studies Sagan kept up his
work with NASA becoming part of the
briefing team for the Apollo 11 crew a
year later II finally sat out his views
on aliens at a UFO symposium the
scientists argued that intelligent life
in our galaxy was a very real
possibility but he also argued against
the idea that aliens were visiting the
earth in UFOs and probing farmers
backsides it was an important
distinction one that distinguished Sagan
from the Roswell obsessed cranks it also
summed up his philosophy neatly per
Sagan UFOs they make no sense they
suggested earth was special that humans
were the center of galactic attention
when rational thought suggested the
opposite would in fact be true
incidentally it was around this time
that Sagan started to get a reputation
among his fellow scientists for being an
egotist who cared more about publicity
stunts than
crunching data the next few years they
would do nothing to dispel this belief
[Music]
by 1971 Sagan was a full professor at
Cornell with a nice side line in
briefing reporters on complex scientific
topics his natural charisma and his
ability to condense complicated ideas
down to an easy to understand analogy he
had made in darling of the serious press
but if Sagan's fellow scientists were
already fed up with his celebrity they
were about to get even fatter a rapper
in 1971 NASA was deep in the final
preparation stages for the Pioneer 10
and 11 probes the most ambitious space
mission to date the twin pioneers were
designed to become the first man-made
objects to pass through the asteroid
belt and investigate the outer planets
but it was this is another detail about
the pioneers that really captured the
public's attention after they completed
their missions that carry on out into
interstellar space if aliens were
monitoring our solar systems fringes
pioneer ten would be the first a
man-made object that they ever
encountered most serious scientists they
paid little attention to this aspect of
pioneer but the idea it captured Carl
Sagan's imagination if an alien
civilization picked up the probe what
would they think Sagan's big
breakthrough was realizing that we could
tell them what to think me months before
the Pioneers launched Sagan contacted
NASA he told them that he wanted to a
fix a plaque to each pioneering case
aliens found them to His infinite
surprise NASA basically said sure why
not
now we really should pause there and
just take a moment to drink in how kind
of insane that is launching a probe into
the farthest reaches of the solar system
is a science so precise that the tiniest
change can throw all of your
calculations totally out of whack and
now a dude has essentially come along
and said that he wants to stick a plaque
on the outside of the thing and yet NASA
authorized it indeed they put millions
of dollars aside for it and so it was
that in 1971 Sagan his wife Linda and
Frank Trigg sat down to write a message
to the universe today the Pioneer plaque
is iconic but even if you've seen it you
might not be aware of quite how detailed
it is the basic idea was to show aliens
who we are and where we come from the
first part was easy the plaque has an
engraving of a naked man and a woman who
are facing outwards the second part was
much much
how do you demonstrate ideas of distance
to a totally alien intelligence one
which has no conception of feet or
meters or anything else like that so you
can hit upon the idea of using a
hydrogen atom the most common element in
the universe hydrogen atoms can exist in
different energy states when they change
States they release a wave of
electromagnetic radiation Sagan Drake
and Linda turn this wave into a
universal measurement the length is
around 21 centimeters the length of time
that light travels in about 0.7 of a
nanosecond Sagan's team gave this
measurements the binary value of 1 they
then used it to describe everything from
the average height of humans to the
distance to the earth that image on the
plaques right that looks like a bunch of
lines exploding out of the dot well then
some maps showing the distance from our
Sun to various neutron stars if an
advanced civilization found it they
could potentially locate our earth from
this map the plaque is a masterpiece of
science and art joined hands in hands
but it's also monumentally useless
although pioneer 10 is aiming in the
vague direction of another star
Aldebaran the chances of either probe
ever encountering intelligent life is so
close to zero you might as well just say
zero people in 1971 they were all too
aware of this it was outraged that Sagan
had known millions of taxpayer dollars
on a picture that would never even be
seen yet Sagan maintains that it was the
right thing to do he wasn't building
that plaque for aliens he was building
it for us here on earth he was building
it to show the public not just what
humanity could do but how big and
wonderful the universe they lived in was
on master ii 1972 pioneer launched
followed shortly after pioneer 11 today
both probes are still out there carrying
Sagan's plaque towards the very edges of
our solar system back on earth the
Pioneer plaque made Sagan an
international celebrity but Sciences
personal publicist wasn't done yet his
greatest achievements it was just around
the corner but just before we get into
that greatest achievement let me tell
you about today's rather appropriate
sponsor
and a big thanks to brilliant for making
these longer videos possible brilliant
are a science learning platform that
allow you to learn through something
called active learning which summed up
is basically the opposite of reading a
super-dense textbook not really
understanding everything and reading the
same page six times over and still not
really guessing it anyone else
probably not just me brilliant use
something called active learning which
is where you read a paragraph and then
you're asked to apply it to a question
which basically means you have to use
that knowledge that you just read and
that is an incredibly effective way to
learn now brilliant cover a whole lot of
science they don't just cover the basics
they go all the way through things like
complex statistics and a whole lot else
now if you've been watching biographic
for a while you've heard me talk about
brilliant before you might have even
signed up to it already so in that case
sorry for wasting your time with another
brilliant adverts but if you haven't
well just go and do it it's a really
perfect fit for this channel because I
mean yours here you're watching a 20
minute educational video on Carl Sagan
brilliant is something you will like I
promise you so just click that link
below and go check it out now recently
brilliant also made an important update
to their mobile app so that the courses
that were previously only accessible
online can now be accessible offline so
you don't have to worry about having a
solid internet connection if you want to
learn something through their platform
maybe you want to pick up something on
your commute into work or well wherever
you are you can access brilliant and
learn something new so yeah if you want
to support by our graphics good thing to
do and get unlimited access to all of
brilliance in-depth math and science
courses or maths as we call it in the UK
or you can head over to brilliant dog
forward slash biographic get 20% off
their annual premium subscription find a
link to that below and let's get back to
you Sagan and his crowning achievement
the next few years saw Sagan establish
himself as the best known scientist in
America he appears on The Tonight Show
with Johnny Carson he became the public
face of NASA's Viking project lens probe
on Mars he also has a not insignificance
effect on the future of popular science
in 1975 a 17 year old Neil deGrasse
Tyson nearly had a heart attack when he
got a letter from Sagan telling him this
Cornell application was inspiring and
inviting him to come and visit sometime
but it was in 1977 that Sagan pulled off
his greatest publicity stunt of all at
the time NASA was preparing to launch
two Voyager probes towards Jupiter and
Saturn and then they would carry on into
interstellar space buoyed by the PR
pioneers plaque had generated the agency
contacted Sagan with a much bigger
proposal they wanted to send a literal
record of humanity into space for aliens
to one day find a NASA they wanted Sagan
to decide what would go on it voyages
Golden Record is today iconic but in
1977 it was a head scratching challenge
pressing a record and encoding it with
instructions would be hard enough but
the real challenge would be choosing
what to put on it to represent humanity
Sagan assembled a team consisting of
himself his wife Linda Frank Drake and
the artist John Lumbergh as well as
Timothy Ferriss contributing editors a
rolling stone he also invited on board
the writer and Riaan and we'll have more
on her in a moment for the next few
months the team worked at a FIFA pitch
tried to cram as much information onto
the record as possible famously this
included samples of human heartbeat
greetings readout in 55 different
languages whale songs and the whole of
Chuck Berry's Johnny be good it also
included a handful of analogue pictures
there were some obvious ones such as the
Taj Mahal and the Golden Gate Bridge the
sort of pictures you'd include if you
were sending up a Lonely Planet guide to
humanity but there were more scientific
ones too DNA structures images
explaining human processes of eating and
drinking athletes performing exercises
but the most interesting was a scan of
the author and rayons brain waves during
the recording process the team reasoned
that a super advanced alien society
could probably take those brainwaves and
decode them so drian was given strict
instructions to think of
certain common objects and then had a
brain scanned for an hour it was only
much much later after Voyager 1 and
Voyager 2 well on their way out of the
solar system the driana admitted that
she hadn't done that she was told on
June the 1st 1977 just before our
brainwaves are monitored she and Sagan
had started an affair her recording was
full of thoughts of the man that she'd
just fallen for that's right the
farthest man-made object in human
history is in part a secret love letter
to the man behind it all Voyager 2
launched in August the 20th 1977 Voyager
1 followed on September the 5th Sagan
describes them eloquently as a message
in a bottle cast into the cosmic sea 35
years later in 2012 Voyager 1 became the
first man-made object to ever enter
interstellar space
although Voyager 2 has since joined it
in November of 2018 it remains the
farthest man-made object from Earth
unless we discover warp drive it's a
record that probably won't be beaten not
long after the probes went up Sagan and
Riaan started looking for a reason to
carry on working together that same year
they hit on the perfect idea they would
write a TV show about science one that
condensed the whole amazing history of
human achievement into 13 hour-long for
provoking episodes the name of that show
cosmos
[Music]
for millions of people their defining
image of Carl Sagan will forever be the
scientist standing on the edges of a low
cliff before a pounding sea describing
the impossible extent of our universe
the first episode of cosmos aired on
September 28th in 1980 three years after
Sagan and Ryan first sat down to start
writing these had not been easy years
there was Sagan on going very
acrimonious divorce from Linda salesmen
for one thing for another there was the
way in 1979 that Sagan's father Samuel
came down with cancer the onset was so
Swift so shocking that Samuel and Rachel
were forced to move in with Sagan and
try on for months Sagan and watched his
father dying unable to tear himself away
from his work on cosmos and Cornell long
enough to give his old man the goodbye
that he deserved
when Samuel finally passed away in
October of 1979 Sagan was devastated yes
life must go on and for Carl Sagan that
meant finishing cosmos for PBS American
Public Television has simply never
created anything as popular since it's
estimated that half a billion people
watch cosmos globally on transmission
what's striking today is how captivating
it remains while the retro 80s graphics
are amusing in hindsight Sagan's
earnestness it still shines through his
feeling of wonder is still enough to
make you want to quit the YouTube
channel that you work on and dedicate
your life to science still not that it's
a perfect show by any stretch the
endless shots of Sagan pulling up
dandelions and gasping in awe at some
computer grafica almost enough to make
you wet yourself trying not to laugh
there's actually a story that's taken
only and then to use one or two of these
shots but he managed to annoy one of the
producers so much that the guy stuck
them into every episode just to try and
make Sagan look as silly as possible
unintentionally hilarious cutaways aside
cosmos still managed to turn Sagan into
a household name had he ended his career
at this point in fact he probably would
be remembered warmly by just about
everyone but Sagan he didn't stop there
instead he followed up cosmos by getting
seriously into activism the turning
point came in 1983 two years before
Sagan had finished divorcing Linda and
married and Ryan and now he was settling
down to life with the woman of his
dreams but it was a life that was very
near least now
away from him that year Sagan went into
hospital for a routine appendectomy and
nearly died he came so close to bleeding
out that only a 10 hour emergency
surgery saved his life when Sagan
recovered he seemed changed by the
experience now he no longer wanted to
merely educate people about the world he
rather wanted to shape it for the better
he began while he was still in the ICU
organizing a mass protest against Ronald
Reagan's new Star Wars missile defense
system a protest that made him unpopular
among Republicans not that Sagan CAD
horrified by US nuclear brinkmanship
with the Soviet Union he attempted to a
win over the public to his cause in 1983
Sagan co-authored the paper that
introduced the concept of a nuclear
winter the idea that even a limited
nuclear exchange would cool the climate
so drastically that famine would wipe
out most of humanity around the same
time Sagan began campaigning against
global warming calling it a threat to
mankind and demanding an international
solution it was a typical Sagan focusing
on the big picture to the detriment of
all else in 1986 even managed to get
himself arrested as an anti-nuclear
event in Nevada for trespassing on
government property in an attempt to
halt underground testing still this was
a minor brush with the law
at best and controversial or nod Sagan
they were still beloved by millions
he was only 52 he had decades left to
win people over to his side didn t
On February the 14th 1990 Voyager 1
turned its camera towards Earth for the
final time from unimaginable millions
upon millions of miles away the probe
snapped a photo of our planet suspended
in a sunbeam the picture was the work of
Carl Sagan who'd convinced NASA to turn
Voyager 1 around for this one moment
when the image finally arrived back on
Earth it changed our conception of our
planet you've almost certainly seen the
pale blue dot photo before almost
certainly felt that sense of war seeing
everything you've ever known reduced to
a tiny speck in the infinity of space
but Sagan wasn't content to simply be
the driving force behind the image he
wanted the picture to make a statement
that mankind could carry through the
ages it's a statement that's worth
quoting at length look again at that dot
that's there that's home that's us
honest everyone you love everyone you
know everyone you've ever heard of every
human being who ever was lived out their
lives the aggregate of our joy and
suffering thousands of confident
religions ideologies and economic
doctrines every hunter and forager every
hero and coward every creator and
destroyer of civilization every King and
peasant every young couple in love every
mother and father hopeful child inventor
and Explorer every teacher of morals
every corrupt politician every superstar
every Supreme Leader every saint and sir
in the history of our species lived
there on a mote of dust suspended in a
sunbeam it has been said that astronomy
is a humbling and character-building
experience there is perhaps no better
demonstration of the folly of human
conceits than this distant image of our
tiny world to me it underscores our
responsibility to deal more kindly with
one another and to preserve and cherish
the pale blue dot the only home we've
ever known if there's ever been a more
perfect summing up of the vastness of
the cosmos or mankind's position within
it well we've yet to hear it for the
consummate publicist Sagan writing this
speech it was just another act in a
career that had already come to define
how we think about space
no way of knowing that this would be his
last great moment the warning signs
they came Saturday in 1994 and noticed a
bruise on Sagan's arm that wouldn't fade
after at first dismissing it sagen
finally went to the hospital for a blood
test a few days later the doctor called
up sounding deeply apologetic they
messed up the samples the doctor set
sagen would have to come for another
test when asked why the doctor replied
that there was no way that this could be
Sagan's blood whose ever it was they
would be dead within months but of
course there had been no mistake sagen
was diagnosed with myelodysplasia a type
of cancer and he was given six months to
live although his sister managed to buy
him some time with an extremely painful
bone-marrow transplants it could only
delay the inevitable on December the
20th 1996 after two grueling and painful
years Carl Sagan died at the age of 62
the astronomer of the people here was no
more for a generation Carl Sagan came to
define how they thought about the
universe he handed them the tools to
make sense of the vast and empty cosmos
around them and in doing so he brought a
sense of hope and of wonder to us all
yet his story may not be over in around
two hundred and ninety six thousand
years Voyager 2 is expected to pass the
great Sun of Sirius in the constellation
Canis Major there it is possible that it
could be intercepted by an alien
civilization a civilization that might
just have the power to decipher the
golden record that is carrying and to
access the data and decode and Ryan's
recorded brainwaves if they did that
then they'd find the image of the man
who'd made that record the faintest
analog memory of the astronomer who
impossibly eons ago had captured dran
heart the chances of this scenario
coming to pass are infinitesimally small
verging on the utterly impossible but
the chance is still there for Carl Sagan
the boy who once looked at the stars
above Brooklyn and dreamed of being
abducted by aliens
the thought that his image could live on
like that no matter how improbable might
have been enough so it really hope you
found that video interesting and
inspiring if you did please do hit that
thumbs up button below and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos just
like this several days a week also
please do check out brilliant saw
fantastic
sponser there's a link to them below and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]